jeudi laurent bouvet et du coup je me
dis que jean luc mélenchon n'est pas à
la hauteur du personnage qu'il est parce
que l île et moi j'aurais aimé
l'entendre dénoncé les propos de la
députée obono sûr j'ai pleuré pour
dieudonné j'ai pas pleurer pour charlie
ou après l'histoire du 2
du conducteur de la ratp qui refusait de
conduire un bus juste après après une
femme c'est des propos qui ne peuvent
pas être tenus par une députée
républicaine et jean luc mélenchon
je suis convaincu qu'au fond de lui il
est en désaccord avec ces a excellé avec
ses propos et il reste ambiguë par
tactique électorale
ça c'est pas bien c'est pas bien